so first thing I want to ask you about
is I think I found out about you
originally because of gamergate now I've
done one video on gamergate it was about
a year ago and I was like enough to it
so basically I said to the audience I
said I said guys look I don't really
understand this thing I don't know
what's going on here I have a sense it
has to do with some people that were
upset at some of the publications and
then all this daxing and oil and
misogyny Rosa but obviously said I don't
know so I don't know that I can address
it now you're in the thick of this thing
so I thought if we do one thing on
gamergate can we do like a five minute
really hash it out honest ever wanted to
know what gamergate was really about
yeah it's five minutes so for you yeah
okay we're all used to seeing these
social justice warriors you got to
police language you say that we're gonna
do plenty of draw nari random things a
sexist or racist or misogynist whatever
I think we're all used to now the press
in some cases reporting on things
extraordinarily badly now gamergate has
been a huge controversy the people who
care about these things because both of
those things have come together it is a
consumer movement that rejects sloppy
standards in reporting about video games
and video games by the way we're a very
important part of the entertainment
industry they're bigger than Hollywood
now 790 probably about by now ninety
billion dollar industry rejects sloppy
reporting about and there all sorts of
horrible infractions of journalistic
ethics and conflicts of interests all
right got it wait just to stay on that
though for a second so basically the the
game companies were sort of paying the
writers to give them better reviews that
is missing heirs and some things like
that going on if in people sleeping with
people and writing things about them a
bit too closely they shouldn't have
basically it's a very fast growing
industry so the press is nascent the
press has grown up very fast and what
was previously a trade press you know
like you know tree cutters weekly or the
stamp collectors monthly or whatever has
suddenly become a consumer press and it
hasn't necessarily improved its
standards commensurate with that right
the second half of it is the social
justice warriors you mentioned briefly
there is a sort of insurgent move in
video games from a couple of wacky
left-wing feminists and these are so far
left Israel hating socialists weirdos
far-left feminists who say that every
video game is problematic there's
something wrong with all these video
games now for some reason the
journalists have sucked all the
and have bought a doll and digit the
same journalists who protected video
games when the religious right in the
1980s and 90s said that video games turn
kids into killers and violent which
there's no evidence I pray we know more
slide none what certain um whatsoever
those same journalists nonetheless have
rolled over and accepted the feminist
critique of video games and said oh well
video games got me violent but they can
make you sexist now again there's no
evidence whatsoever that's the case yeah
the research is this the most generous
you could be is to say the research is
you know that the jury's out yeah but
most of this most most of the most
credible research says there's nothing
in it right so to be real clear on that
so that would be like for example in a
game like Grand Theft Auto where you can
literally grab a woman out of her car
hunt you're healing up but you can do
that to a man - so you would you would
argue that that that's not what the anti
woman because they're there it's close
to whole list of all it's imaginary it's
not real and second second of all it's
on its computer screen yeah and second
of all what much of the evidence shows
actually is that people who get stuff
out of their system and it's mainly boys
who get the stuff out of their system
playing video games are nicer to people
in the real world because it's that sort
of boyish testosterone thing I mean even
as homosexuals we have some
understanding of that male need to sort
of win and crush and you know and do
that kind of I like to think so well you
know you know you probably play sports I
don't but you know I take that out
horizontally but yeah um there is it
there is that sort of male need to get
you know get that sort of testosterone
energy out of the system and when boys
do that in video games much of the
evidence shows that they behave nicely
in real life now some up some studies
say that video games can make you hyper
competitive so the FIFA games the
football games can leave somebody a bit
more competitive can raise the
testosterone levels but that's a very
temporary effect there's absolutely no
evidence whatsoever the video games can
make you sexist and these sorts of
cherry-picked insane feminists I mean
just just just the most barmy bonkers
although you know we'll get on to
feminism later but yeah um it's coming
if you imagine the most wacky
stereotypical blue haired overweight
furious you know fact-free terrible
lesbian you know lesbionic feminists
whether all lesbians now lesbionic
feminists kind of lunatic that's the
sort of person who's criticizing
videogames and very often the people
don't even play video
this is this is another chapter in the
culture wars which we're used to from
the movies and from books Norris so
gamergate game ordinary gamers have put
up for 10 years or more with their own
press calling them man babies and
misogynists beating up on them basically
because it's the trendy thing to do
because these days progressivism and you
know sort of hating on men that kill all
white men kind of these feminist
hashtags that are socially acceptable
I mean you there is no you will get no
social censure from your peers as a as a
member of the media today for tweeting
one of those hashtags now obviously if
you did it the other way around it would
be a problem that's become fashionable
become trendy for white is this little
white guilt right white middle-class
girl is become fashionable for these
people to beat up on themselves
prostrate themselves before the altar of
womanhood and say that everything that
they are and everything that they do is
terrible how I'm so sorry you know
mother Gaia how can I make it up to you
the reality is that actually these video
games quite good for people so that's
the crux of it then it's it's these
people it's the gaming community that
that has risen up because it's been that
it is tired of being lied about and
slandered by its own press press they
did a really good job of defending it
when the violent stuff is going on Jack
Thompson in the 90s for the same video
games can make you violent the press did
a really good job of rebutting him yeah
as he was conservative but when a
liberal winner progressive critic comes
along they fall over themselves to agree
and start hating on their own audience
right and that's really interesting and
it goes to really what 90% of what we're
going to talk to talk about is about
because right I remember when when joe
lieberman who's uh you know was on the
right at that time i guess he's an
independent now when he was railing
against violence in video games with
mortal kombat i remember it was very
cool to say what what a loser he was and
so out of touch well the problem with
some the problem in video games from
with gamers is they have no social
capital everybody hates them the right
hates video games because it says they
cause school shootings and because
they're violent and a bit and deviant
and dorky and you've got the sort of
from the religious right that complains
that they're you know can introduce
dangerous you know thoughts of
individuals minds nobody was killing
anybody in the name of god before video
games right well i never happened we can
talk about that later
omething atheists will get offers
um there's you know
doing this in the 90s writing the games
press did a great job of defending
defending video games against those
charges they've done a much less job
good job in fact they've done no job at
all of defending it against feminists
who are just as wacky and just as crazy
as the old religious right and in fact
the feminists say all the same things
they hate the same things they hate
nudity and violence they're all the same
stuff this is why some very clever
Brendan O'Neill there's a wonderful
comest and Britton wrote in The
Spectator a great thing about it was a
provocation but it was it was
interesting about how feminism looks
quite a lot like Islamism in some
regards they because it hates the same
things they hates female nudity X you
know was it any ask for the same staff
and it has uses the same language I
wrote I did a silly quiz online in my
column about Anita sarkeesian who is the
leading feminist critic of video games
or Jack Thompson who was the 90s
religious right guy and I just sort of
lined up a load of quotes from each of
them and asked you know you had to go
and your to pick which who said it and
no but nobody got more than 5 out of 10
which is my point
right they say the same thing same
language and it goes to that that
difference is not really about left and
right it's not about politics anymore
the most important political distinction
in people since more of our what as more
of our lives move online more of our
discourses online as more people
navigate the internet what the Internet
has done to politics is very interesting
it has turned every major culture war
and every major discussion into a row
between authoritarians want to control
how other people live and libertarians
who either you know want to escape into
fantasy worlds because they know to
escape you know what I was going on
their life or simply classical liberals
like me who believe in freedom of
expression freedom of thought liberty of
of idea and and and believe that it is
essential for you know the good of our
species if you like it if you want to
get serious about it that we can talk
about everything openly and honestly and
that there are no no-go areas I'm what
my colleague at Breitbart Alan Bukhari
caused a cultural libertarian I'm not a
libertarian politically speaking but I
believe that in culture there should be
no boundaries and that we should be able
to explore everything video games are
assailed on all sides from the left from
the right from everybody by people who
want to restrict the acceptable limits
of a creative expression I think that's
dangerous I think it's dangerous
wherever it happens I think video games
are the most interesting entertainment
medium in which it's happening now
because it is that because the gamers
are the first people who rose
and said no to the social justice
warriors and it was a horrible and
humiliating defeat for them right so
it's actually interesting and then we'll
move on to to feminism specifically but
it's really interesting because this is
sort of the awakening that I now see
happening in our political discussion
people are now hitting on this
libertarian thing and fighting the
authorities burning some but it's
certainly it's Bernie Sanders it's Trump
it's Faraj and Corbin in the UK all of
the populist political movements on the
left and the right they come all over
the counter counter cultural
anti-establishment libertarian leanings
right now Corbin in the UK is much more
of a socialist he's much more of a of a
prescriptive kind of guy but his
supporters you know want to be able to
behave terribly and they do behave
terribly just was it this week they were
spitting on people in the Tory
conference in Manchester they want the
right not just to think terrible things
like I do micro just a cultural Liberty
and they want the right to behaved
abominably all of this stuff you know is
is it comes from the you know think I
think something we've all known for 10
20 years it's increasing dissatisfaction
alienation from the political and media
relates that a lot of ordinary voters
feel yeah ordinary people I think pretty
much everybody feels that regardless I
think what I think they do and even I
think we'll get onto this later even
those of us who work in the media have
quite knifes lives and come from nice
homes and you know and don't really have
much to complain about still feel that
quite acutely and you and I think are
examples of people who are a bit more
alive to that a bit more aware of the
fact that the you know that um political
discourse and cultural discussion on
television has become really really dull
yeah and you've had people on your show
already in the first thing wounds right
and you've had people in your show in
the first three episodes who are very
insistent about free speech and free
expression and the importance of old
Victorian style classical liberalism but
also the importance of mischief and joy
and a little bit of fun like magic no
Majid namazi got on sure who is a great
lover of fun and mischief and loves to
tease people who want to lecture him and
bully him and the leftists who say to
him that he's not a proper Muslim or
whatever you know because he doesn't
want to keep women burkas or whatever it
is right what is this which that to me
seems racist if you say well he's not
being good about but all right
we racism but you see we started with
gamergate we do you see where we ended
here your game again this is what they
gave me at us and I'll tell you why is
it I get in them again bring a super or
super I promise yeah the reason gaming
it does this is gaming it is
is a sort of final it's almost at the
final chapter in two decades whether the
internet wars and those internet wars
have been about thought speech culture
politics you name it every community on
the internet and every sub community
within those sites with four channel
reddit whatever has a dog in the fight
in gamergate because they all either
have a vested interest in free speech
and anonymity or they have an interest
in protecting the integrity integrity
and creative expression of certain
attainment mediums or their their
individual people who have behaved
terribly on the internet who saw
gamergate as a redemptive opportunity so
if they lined up with you know the women
and went in with these mostly fake
threats about death and rape and all the
rest of it
typical leftist feminist tactics that
don't stack up when you look into them
which we'll get into a challenge missus
agate lining up on one side that debate
was a way of indicating whether you were
for authoritarianism install of these
nascent arguments and wars online and
and and gamergate takes you in these
crazy directions because in a way it's
sort of the most all-encompassing war
and the most all-encompassing event
that's ever happened on the internet
because it brought in everybody all of
the old battles you know something
people don't always realize when you
range up the sides on gamergate there
are people who were involved in wars
five years ago kind of take picking the
same sorts of sides this is it this is
the best example we have yet the most
exciting example culturally we haven't
journalists on such a terrible idea a
terrible job of reporting on this
concentrating these fake great threats
conservatives have missed the missed the
huge cultural opportunity here
shamefully so leftist have not even
bothered to make the arguments because
they know their arguments are nonsense
and they focused on the threats this was
such an interesting example of what I
was saying earlier the fact that on the
internet it's not about left and right
anymore
it's about authoritarians and
libertarians yeah and cultural
libertarians are the rising power and
they're the people who love me they're
the people I think much of your audience
falls into the same bucket actually the
people have Lauren southern the
libertarian Canadian politician they
love Cathy young a great veteran
journalist of christina hoff sommers at
the American Enterprise Institute Adam
Baldwin the actor but all of the even
Eli Roth the director is making a baekje
movie about social justice yeah right
now you know cultural libertarianism is
on the rise because people are sick of
political correctness people are sick of
being told their racist sexist
misogynist transphobic
and then of the north
you